(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This is Julia,
a Thick Billed Parrot.
They are the only surviving parrot species
native to North America.
A combination of the illegal
pet trade, habitat loss,
and global warming has
left this beautiful bird
endangered in the wild.
These medium sized
parrots are bright green
with a black beak and red markings
on their head, shoulders, and legs.
The majority of their diet
is composed of pine seeds,
but they also feed on berries,
insects and tree bark.
Their thick bill is
capable of breaking through
practically every nut on earth.
Thick Billed Parrots live in
high elevation pine forests
in northern Mexico.
They used to be found in
Arizona and New Mexico,
but because of hunting and predation,
they haven't been seen
in the United States
for over 20 years.
Experts estimate that there are only
three to 6,000 left in the wild.